hello everyone oh good we can hear
everyone all nicely welcome to bus boys
and poets my name is olivia i am the
book events coordinator here
and i'm very excited to welcome alec
mcpherson for his book ghosts of
sheridan circle
um it's a
event that i was not aware of honestly
and was very excited to read about it in
this book and i'm excited for alan to
speak about it here at bus boys we like
to have conversations that others aren't
having and i feel like this is one of
those so i'm excited for him to speak
about it i'm going to give you a little
kind of overview if you have a cell
phone please take photos but don't make
the flash happen we are filming tonight
as you probably can see that's a little
distracting
we will have the books for sale we have
them for sale currently and
if you would like to i really implore
you to look through it and have alan
sign it he'll be signing afterwards as
well
we have a wonderful server aisha in the
room isha will be here all night so
please
take care of her as she will take care
of you
i will now turn it on over to alan for
the
talk of ghosts of sheridan circle thank
you all thanks
thank you very much olivia
thank you to bless boys and poets for
hosting this i also want to thank my
publisher university of north carolina
press for putting this together
uh the few institutions also who you
know made this book happen in washington
i'm so happy to be presenting this in
washington which is you know literally
the scene of this crime
um
the institute for policy studies is very
important in you know letting me uh
interview them and and
keep the memory of this book alive for
40 plus years also the embassy of chile
was very helpful
so let me begin with the first words
from this book
and these are the people talking
isabel i have a surprise for you have
lunch with me
today will be difficult i have work
but you will love the surprise orlando
lately insisted come and get me at 12 30
and leave your work for the afternoon
isabella tellier exceeded after all her
husband was a
charmer besides there was no time to
argue it was 9 a.m time for orlando to
go to work at the institute for policy
studies in washington dc's dupont circle
he had been at the leftist think tank
for nearly two years
using ips as a platform to undermine
general augusto pinochet the iron fisted
dictator who had overthrown the
government of president salvador allende
of chile
litiga had been a yen day's ambassador
to the united states
then his minister with three portfolios
now
as a private uh citizen he exposed
pinochet's human rights atrocities
incited boycotts and discouraged
investment
two of orlando's colleagues happened to
ride with him that day
michael and ronnie moffat both 25 and
recently married
the moffetts waited while atelier ever
tardy showered and dressed skipped
breakfast and rushed out the door
isabelle barely had time to kiss him
goodbye
orlando took the wheel of his 1975
chevrolet chevelle malibu classic
out of gallantry michael moffatt opened
the front passenger door for ronnie he
plotted himself on the back seat
that september 21 1976 was a drizzly
misty morning in the nation's capital
in less than an hour orlando and ronnie
would be dead michael will be
traumatized for life
this is the actual car after the bombing
on sheridan
circle i never learned what the surprise
was isabelle recalled when i interviewed
her over 40 years after this event
to this day the killing of orlando
italian and ronnie moffatt remains the
only assassination of a foreign diplomat
on u.s soil it's also the only
state-sponsored assassination ever in
washington and the most important in u.s
history
until osama bin laden assessed one
historian the lately of moffett
assassinations constituted the most
brazen act of international terrorism
ever committed in the capital of the
united states
it is still the only state-sponsored
such act and the only car bomb
the two-decade-long resolution of this
case would hold implications for chile
the united states terrorism human rights
and the fate of democracy everywhere
my book notably argues that it was
crucial in taking down the entire
pinochet government
but today i want to explore a sub-theme
of the book
two opposing forces fascism one on one
side and human rights on the other
that clashed during these decades and
that outlived the communist capitalist
ideological struggle of the cold war
these forces are still with us today and
lately assassination brought them into
open conflict
and so on the cover you have on top here
you've got the car on the bottom but on
top you've got orlando lately on the
right and ronnie moffat on the left
the order to assassinate letelier was
not simply an overreaction by an
anti-communist regime
although it was that
it was also rooted in the fascism that
lurked inside post-war latin american
political culture
in chile that fascism partly came from
germany
in the 19th century southern chile
attracted 30 000 settlers from the
german states
a military mission from prussia shaped
up chile's troops resulting in the grey
uniforms and the goose stepping of the
daunting chilean army
in the 20th century the mostly
fair-skinned well-to-do germans of
southern chile filled the ranks of
far-right parties
they cheered and marched when hitler
came to power
the nazis of chile boasted 60 000
members electing three to the national
legislature
in 1938 they attempted a failed push in
santiago
after world war ii southern communities
became favorite destinations for former
nazi officers fleeing persecution
throughout fascism in chile not only a
dare to all of nazi germany's tenets
anti-semitism anti-communism state
control of the economy hierarchical
leadership and intense nationalism
but also added its own a love of all
things spain
the traditions of
catholicism a rejection of empire and
the championing of latin american unity
made this among the most potent
totalitarianisms in latin america
anduel contreras the man on the right
here was the head of the secret police
who gave the order to kill lately
he grew up in this germanized south of
chile after world war ii he admired the
spanish dictator francisco franco
when pinochet and his allies overthrew a
yen day on september 11 1973
contreros was in on it
on september 10th
his son threaded over an english exam
the next day
contreras looked at him and smiled don't
worry you're not going to school
tomorrow
right after the coup pinochet made
contreras the head of the national
intelligence directorate
known as dina
a colonel contreras now answered to no
general minister or judge
only to pinochet
dina dominated all other intelligence
agencies
its 9 300 employees could raid homes and
jail suspects without charges and its 20
to 30 000 informants spread fear
throughout other chilean government
agencies its logo featuring an iron
glove dina was responsible for about
1200 of the 3 200 executions under
pinochet
the associations between dina and
fascism were legion
it was alleged that its employees
engaged in rituals harking back to
bygone warrior myths the use of runes an
ancient germanic alphabet and a
celebration of solstices and equinoxes
to revive nazism
dina members addressed each other as
pharaohs priests and slaves denoting
their status within the hierarchy
contreras even allied with former nazi
paul schaefer of colony of dignity
infamy by using schaefer's enclave as a
detention and torture center
the u.s department of defense compared
dina to hitler's gestapo
when franco died in 1975 pinochet flew
to madrid for the funeral and contreras
took a plane full of officers along
franco supporters lined up on the avenue
from the airport and gave the chileans
motorcade the stiff-armed fascist salute
in my book i call contreras the himmler
of the andes
september 11th
orlando lately served as chile's
minister of defense
when he showed up to his ministry after
hearing rumors of a coup plotters took
him prisoner and shipped him to dawson
island a nazi-style concentration camp
in the deep frozen south of chile and
somebody luckily took a photo of him
being arrested by his own men
there and in other detention centers he
would remain for a year never charged
with a crime psychologically tortured
and emaciated until the venezuelan
government obtained his freedom
before his release lately was told in no
uncertain words
general pinochet will not and does not
tolerate activities against his
government still atelier ended up
working against pinochet in washington
his work coincided with a golden age of
human rights activism in the mid 1970s
more than 200 groups in the united
states worked on human rights
over 50 lobbied congress and about 15
concentrated on latin america
civil rights icon patricia darian became
the first assistant secretary of state
for democracy human rights and labor
under the jimmy carter administration
just a few months after the little
assassination
mark schneider her deputy had worked for
senator edward kennedy of massachusetts
on several u.s latin american issues
in congress representative don frazier
chaired the first congressional hearings
on human rights in 1973
helping him were among others tom harkin
michael harrington toby moffett and
george miller in the house and kennedy
james james iburesk and george mcgovern
in the senate
these were all democrats
on chile congress's greatest achievement
was the 1975 harkin amendment which cut
off aid to any government that grossly
violated human rights
unless the president determined that
such aid would directly benefit the
needy the following year teddy kennedy
directly targeted chile marking the
first time the congress added military
aid to another government because of
human rights
one chilean magazine called kennedy the
most dangerous foreign adversary of the
pinochet regime
lately health byronian michael moffatt
worked at this environment at the
institute for policy studies one of the
most influential human rights
organizations in the country
he met with top state department
officials he taught at american
university
he launched with senators
angela davis once came to his house john
baez was a friend richard avedon
photographed him
most important lately became a unifier
for chilean exiles numbering in the
hundreds of thousands worldwide
he also convinced holland's dock workers
federation to boycott the handling of
chilean goods and therefore won the
cancellation of a planned 62 million
dollar mining investment in chile
these two things seem to have convinced
pinochet to order latelier's
assassination
roughly from 1975 to 1983 contreras and
his south american allies killed several
hundred people outside chile
at looking away from such brutalities
national security adviser and secretary
of state henry kissinger became an
expert
one month before lotelier was killed
kissinger's state department prepared a
memo signed by kissinger that instructed
southern cone ambassadors to express the
south american dictators washington's
quote deep concern over their plans for
the assassination of subversives
politicians and prominent figures both
within the national borders of certain
southern cone countries and abroad
so in other words the state department
was supposed to tell south american
dictators not to kill people outside of
south america
but for one month none of the
ambassadors who received this cable from
washington did anything about it which
is very rare in diplomacy usually when
you're given an order you do it
the ambassador to uruguay feared for his
life if he wagged his finger at the
generals
the envoy to chile worried that pinochet
quote might well take as an insult any
inference that he was connected with
such assassination plots
five days before the lately
assassination kissinger ordered quote
that no further action be taken on this
matter
back in chile in the same summer of 1976
contreras acting through his chief of
operations pedro pedro espinosa
entrusted the hit on the tail year to
michael townley a chilean the an
american chilean explosives expert
and this is michael townley with his
wife
during the allende years townley worked
with proto-fascist youth shock troops
called fatherland and freedom
recruits to follow fatherland and
freedom received training in coding and
code breaking weapons handling
explosives and martial arts with
nunchucks
later paulo rodriguez would regularly
line up his troops as he called them and
he reviewed them with his right arm
crossed against his chest
remember these are teenagers right
they're not soldiers
they wore black uniforms with white
armbands adorned with a swastika-like
insignia that united chain links
and resemble the spider
hitler's brown shirts would have
approved
allende's followers called fallen and
freedom a bunch of fascists paid by the
cia
and it turns out they were correct
rodriguez their leader denied accepting
cia funding but the truth is that in
fall 1970 kissinger requested and
received 38 thousand dollars for covert
support of fodderland and freedom this
fascist organization
others in the group admitted receiving
those funds and added that an extra five
thousand dollars per month filtered in
so back to townley the bomb maker he
embraced the rhetoric and the actions of
fatherland and freedom and started
making bombs for them
the masses are not ready to govern
themselves he said democracy leads only
to mass government ruled by the herd
power should be reserved for the
qualified few the intellectuals the
philosopher kings
in the united states townley connected
with about five cuban americans
also proto-fascists
they call themselves the cuban
nationalist movement headquartered in a
new jersey newly cubanized since fidel
castro's 1959 revolution by the 1970s
these cuban americans were also
disenchanted with the u.s government
which had dropped them as assets against
castro
here's a picture of a few of them in
their headquarters in new jersey along
with their logo
which has the island of cuba
with the number three which means sort
of uh not communism not capitalism but a
third way and a lightning strike against
communism uh which essentially meant
violence against against cuba
like contreras these cuban americans had
decided to kill opponents throughout the
world
soon bombs exploded in new york montreal
miami lima mexico city merida kingston
madrid london and paris
between 1974 and 1976 u.s authorities
tied 202 major bombings in 23 countries
to cuban exiles one every five days on
average and 113 of them in the united
states
in 1974 cuban exiles accounted for 45
percent of all terrorist bombings on the
planet
the cuban nationalist movement's motto
cuba before all recalled nazi germany's
deutschland uber alice
its pamphlets outlined an ideology
centered on a syndicalist capitalism
akin to those of mussolini hitler franco
and chile's fatherland in freedom
one cuban member of a more mainstream
organization dismissed the cnm as
right-wing extremists and fascists
one of these cubans once asked michael
townley and his wife during a dinner
what do you think about the world jewish
conspiracy
now remember they're trying to fight
communism
i beg your pardon the what said
townley's wife the jewish conspiracy is
going to destroy the world if we don't
fight it before we do anything else we
must destroy the jews
it seems to me she told him that you've
gotten sidetracked on purpose fidel
castro is too difficult to target so you
have chosen to perennial target the jews
naturally it's easier to fight the jews
than the cubans
still these cuban americans helped
townley build the car bomb and install
it under lately year's car
one cuban drove behind him on the
morning of september 21st 1976 while
another pushed the button on the
detonator
so for washington the challenge at the
lately assassination posed was in
clarifying the divisions between those
such as kissinger who enabled fascism to
infiltrate the chilean government
those such as teddy kennedy who
championed human rights and the vast
majority in the middle who needed the
car bombing to prompt them to care
enough
early on mainstream us observers tended
towards absolving the chilean regime the
new york times editors concluded that
quote it is hard to believe that even as
ham handed the regime as chiles junta
would order the murder of so eminent an
opponent as mr letelier in the capital
of the united states
the national security council writing
the day of the assassination admitted
that quote right-wing chileans are the
obvious candidates but they seem to be
too obvious
thankfully investigation was not up to
the nsc it was the job of the fbi and
the attorney general's office
these men led by eugene proper were
anti-communists but also gifted
technocrats dedicated to solving this
murder wherever it took them
and this is eugene proper the head of
the investigation
in chile
for almost 18 months the fbi had no
solid lead on this case
it heard of a mysterious gringo among
chileans but had no name right turns out
it was michael townley it heard rumors
that cuban americans
rumors from cuban americans a grand
journey subpoenaed them a grand jury
subpoenaed them but they kept mum
and the investigation kept getting
threats just as orlando and isabelle had
before the assassination i'll give you a
few examples of these threats
on october 4 an unknown male called
orlando latelier's aunt maria del solar
maria maria maria he said
condescendingly talking to the fbi won't
help you your legs will be spread in
washington dc just like orlando's then
he hung up
in early november investigator larry
wax's fiancee a flight attendant about
to join her crew was standing at kennedy
airport rifling through her purse for
her key to an american airlines office
suddenly a man grabbed her arm and
yanked her around
you tell your little friend larry watt
to keep his [ __ ] nose out of chile's
business
well you won't be so pretty anymore boom
boom you know what i mean
this kind of thing happened over and
over again in the investigation to the
fbi to the judges to the lawyers and of
course to anybody who talked to the fbi
if they can do this and get away with it
under the nose of the cia and the fbi
said president-elect jimmy carter in
november 1976 then no president can
govern and he was talking about the
lately assassination
on one hand carter meant that such a
brazen attack on a chilean's dissident
on u.s soil was unacceptable to the u.s
policy-making apparatus whether
republican or democrat
it made the united states look unable to
police its own borders
it made the cold war seem out of control
on the other hand foreign policy makers
were careful about pushing a cold war
ally too hard
a u.s political officer in chile
explained that we were not against the
chilean government we were not against
what the military had done which means
the overthrow of allende we were against
the abuse of it and the terrorism that
had been performed in its name
so it was often up to regular people
like isabel atelier michael moffatt and
human rights organizations such as the
institute for policy studies to pressure
carter officials against the chileans
first to expel townley from chile which
proved successful and second to
extradite contreras and other chileans
which proved a failure
when pinochet once traveled to
washington carter met him in the oval
office and brought up human rights and
his carter's determination to get to the
bottom of littelier crime
pinochet nodded and promised cooperation
but my book reveals how behind the
scenes the dictator orchestrated a
cover-up
letelia and moffatt therefore
meaning the widow and the widower
were aghast moffat asked at a press
conference if carter is serious about
human rights why doesn't he welcome
isabel and me just like he's welcoming
pinochet
the widow and widower wrote the
president
for a meeting but national security
advisers big new brzezinski denied them
brzezinski didn't help at all letelier
told me we could never get through to
him never
and she remembered this in her late
eighties
in her activism lately focused attention
on pinochet's likely responsibility for
the assassination
college and local newspapers covered her
as did local radio and television this
is the human rights network when the
right-wing media in the u.s tried to
smear orlando as a tool of fidel castro
isabel isabel debunked their lies
the dam finally burst when in march 1978
investigators published photos of the
two men whose name they ignored but whom
they suspected of being involved so they
had these passport photos but they
didn't have the names
they just knew that these men had come
to washington during the assassination
or at least before it
within days chileans identified townley
and his friend armando fernandez as the
two men from chile who were in the
united states during the assassination
gene proper and co-investigator carter
kornick landed in santiago the following
morning
proper and his beard roused some
suspicions among conservative chilean
officials was he a hippie a jew
the americans saw no trace of a chilean
manhunt for townley just as the chileans
pretended they were looking for him they
were certain that instead the chileans
were prevaricating while hiding townley
there were also consummate professionals
among the diplomats u.s ambassador
george landau for instance demanded a
meeting with the chilean foreign
minister
there he dropped all the diplomatic
politics he had practiced over his
career and threatened that if townley
was not made to answer the us
government's questions all u.s relations
with chile would be endangered trade
loans investment diplomatic relations
frankly i don't believe your people are
trying very hard landau blurred which is
a rare thing for an ambassador to say
shortly after
on the 15th floor of the building out of
which he ruled pinochet's political team
met setting at its task keeping townley
in chile
suddenly the french doors of the meeting
room swung open and then walked pinochet
himself
the dictator rarely descended below his
22nd floor
this meant something
please continue don't mind me the strong
man instructed his advisors while he
paced behind their chairs
then of course he interrupted
we were doing so well so well ready to
take off and then this
this is a banana peel senores
if we step on it the government will
fall we will fall
as abruptly as he entered he left the
room
pinochet's anxiety seemed to change the
momentum of the meeting
talk of avoiding townley's expulsion
switched to handing him over to the
americans
within weeks therefore townley was
stateside spilling all the chilean
secrets on the assassination
he served about three years in u.s
prisons and is likely now still living
in the witness protection program
three cuban americans were also tried
but their guilty verdicts were soon
after thrown out on technicalities
the champions of human rights had won a
limited victory
but pinochet remained in power and
contreras though demoted remained free
the chilean courts refused to extradite
him espinosa and fernandez the three
chileans who were directly involved in
this
my book is the first to recount what
happened over the next 15 years
after about 1980 the story shifted to
chile where fascists and human rights
champions again remained in conflict
isabel letalia and her family kept the
legal case technically alive against
contreras espinosa and fernandez but
held out little hope of an actual trial
while pinochet was in power
in the u.s the reagan government
repealed carter's already weak sanctions
crucially however democrats in congress
um
forced the executive to quote unquote
certify that chile was making progress
on the lately moffatt case in order to
allow military to military relations so
it's the democrats in congress who
forced reagan to be tough on pinochet
it took a few breaks in the late 1980s
and early 1990s to reinvigorate
reinvigorate the case in chile
the first break was the defection in
1987 of armando fernandez right the
other guy in the passport photos
he had surveyed l'italia in washington
hadn't committed a particularly serious
crime
for the first time american officials
heard all the details about pinochet's
orchestration of the cover-up
fernandez ended up spending only 21
months in chilean hospitals and u.s
prisons but it was the first conviction
of a chilean military man in u.s courts
it also seems to have led the cia to
conclude that pinochet not only covered
up the crime but also ordered the hit
and this is a conclusion that only came
to light in 2015.
in 1990 another defection of sorts
confirmed fernandez's story
a woman named monica lagos a former
dancer and later an escort for dina had
accompanied fernandez to washington to
act as his wife under the pseudonym
liliana walker
she had disappeared from everyone's
radar and spent much of the 1980s
suffering from debilitating alcoholism
drug addiction and schizophrenia
on april 17 1990 chileans awoke to a
dramatic front page headline
in that morning's la epoca newspaper
i am liliana walker it declared
accompanied by a 1976 passport photo an
intrepid journalist had found monica
lagos living at her parents house
at this point the reagan and bush
governments had turned against peninsula
the democratic opposition led the way
the press the press felt free to
criticize the regime and as a result
pinochet lost a referendum on his rule
in early 1990 a new democratic
government was in power
because of the fernandez and lagos
confessions the l'etelier case could now
be reopened in chilean courts because
there was new evidence
three years later they found contreros
and espinosa guilty
in 1995 the supreme court of chile
ratified the decisions
contreras spent the rest of his life in
detention until he died in 2015.
espinosa is still in prison
the lately affair stands as one of the
most consequential assassinations of the
cold war
in chile the lately request for justice
brought about the dissolution of dina
and eventually defanged the country's
amnesty law which prevented the
persecution of pinochet era atrocities
it forced the reagan government to put
decisive diplomatic and financial
pressure on the dictatorship
contreras and espinosa were the first of
pinochet's military officers to go to
prison and among the first cold war
violators of human rights in latin
america or anywhere to go to prison
the case sparked a movement that has
adjudicated more than a thousand cases
of human rights violations in chile
alone
the story also demonstrates the
transnational power of human rights a
civil case against the chile for
instance represented the first wrongful
death case ever brought in the united
states against the foreign nation and it
culminated in a payment of millions of
dollars to the litigators and moffats
this is in the early 1990s
in addition the lately affair broke down
the us intelligence community's wall
separating domestic from international
terrorism
blending human rights and
counterterrorism advances the case
produced additional firsts the first
deal against extradition when the united
states had an expedition treaty with
another country
the first charges ever filed in the
american legal system against
cuban-american terrorists the first
conviction of a chilean military man in
u.s courts and the first live telecast
of chilean court proceedings
in civil courts the case became the
first filed under the foreign sovereign
immunities act that dealt with terrorism
in 1996 it led to a law that stripped
immunity from a foreign state when
damages were sought against specific
terrorist acts
said one u.s diplomat the lately
assassination in respect was one of the
most stupid things done by any
government
that certainly is true
pinochet contreras and townley did not
understand the implications of car
bombing a former ambassador and a u.s
citizen in the heart of washington
it took decades but their monstrous deed
backfired contributing in no small part
to ending their ideological dream their
government and in the last two cases
their personal freedom
all these the results of a movement of
human rights activists who correctly
identified the fascist core of the
pinochet regime thank you very much
[Applause]
questions we can take some questions
from the audience i have a wireless mic
that i can walk around with if anyone
has a question just raise your hand
a little bit about the research that you
did for the book and the inner
i'm happy
right
well i did research on three continents
essentially right north america
latin america and europe
um
when i began this uh it was about 2 2014
and i thought all the documents were out
right i figured i just need to go and
find them
then i realized while i was at this
amazing archive called the national
security archive here in washington
while i was doing research there
i realized shortly after that we weren't
done declassifying materials and so
new declassifications came out in 2015
and 2016. among those as i mentioned in
my talk
were the cia documents that basically
concluded that uh finished not only
covered up the crime but also ordered
the hit
up to that point
this had only been
sort of a
uh somebody that something that
everybody knew was true but nobody had
any evidence right that finished ordered
but the cia said now we are concluding
this and so it has now become
essentially right an official finding of
la tell your assassination
i found great documents at the institute
of policy studies
not in dc but their archive in wisconsin
of all places the wisconsin historical
society has all the archives of
not only letelia who worked there but
his colleagues and his widow so once he
was killed she essentially took over his
job did a lot of human rights work
and there are several sort of
psychological
follow-throughs on how this had
traumatized her traumatized michael
moffett who also worked at ips
traumatized their children i mean she
and orlando had four teenage sons when
this happened
and so those are amazing documents that
really allow you to follow this story in
in a humane way and sort of in a in a
human way how these you know people were
traumatized for decades after this
in chile
i found the documents of l'etelier
family itself
they haven't been in archives for very
long maybe five ten years i'm not not
sure a lot of people have worked on them
but they are amazing letters notably
letters that
litelier and his wife wrote to each
other when he was in that concentration
camp essentially in patagonia and he was
almost freezing to death and losing you
know 30 50 pounds
um and they were sending love letters to
each other i mean they're they're
beautiful and his kids are sending
letters i mean you got to realize these
are teenage boys
and they're sending letters to their
their father who's in a concentration
camp and you know he could die at any
time and there's nothing they can do
about it
i interviewed her
in santiago i interviewed
two of her kids who are now right in
their late 50s uh living in the united
states and interviewed a bunch of other
people who were you know connected to
the case in some way so it's been it's
been a fascinating sort of uh research
adventure
sure
can you expand a little bit on the
reaction on the us government the first
few days after
the uh
you talked about it briefly
right
sure i'm glad to uh the question was
about the reaction of the us government
in the first few days after the car
bombing
i mean remember this happens during the
ford administration
so
henry kissinger is still
the secretary of state
[Music]
carter will be elected about a month and
a half
in the future right so there's an
election going on
so the response i mean we have no real
response from ford that have been
recorded but we have internal documents
from right department of defense
department of state
and the general sense is that well
finishes you know dina probably did this
um but it seems too obvious right this
is what i'm quoting um they're looking
at sort of all the options and the
options include not just dina but it
could be sort of a a rogue force within
the government or paramilitary force it
could also be and this is something
that many people think are trying to
spread this idea that it could be the
extreme left
it could be these leftist guerrillas who
are organizing violently against
finishing
and so the pinochet government gloms on
to this explanation they say of course
this is must be what it is
right because it can't possibly be dina
it can't possibly be right this
righteous anti-communist government it's
got to be these extreme anti-communists
these extreme communists excuse me
and they want to pin it on us they want
to make it look like it's us
and so inside the u.s government you
immediately have
you know a bit of a tug of war you've
got people saying this but you've also
got people going it might be the extreme
left but it's probably pinochet right
pinochet really has the means and the
motivation to do this sort of thing
and also you know there's a tug of war
between the fbi and the cia they don't
particularly get along at this point uh
the cia's done a lot of dirty work in
south america it's been allied with most
of these governments and it's
essentially given a green light that
these governments can do pretty much
what they want in terms of human rights
and it's not going to stop them
now the fbi doesn't really work abroad i
mean partly it has some folks abroad but
it mostly
takes care of crimes in the united
states one thing it does is immediately
take this crime away from the washington
dc police they say we can't trust the dc
police plus these are clearly federal
crimes right even though they happen in
washington we're going to control them
and
we're a little bit afraid of what the
cia is going to do about this because if
we ask them to let's say
contact their chilean operatives not
only could they burn bridges but they
will
give them some of our information and so
we don't want to waste our information
or lose our information through the cia
right because they don't really trust
the motivations of the cia cia wants to
win the cold war
right whereas the fbi wants to solve
this crime right one crime at a time so
the cia is much more ideological much
more in line and so there's immediately
a type of war but clearly the
prerogative is that of the cia of the
fbi and the department of justice
uh early in your talk you mentioned the
fund of money uh from the cia
that went through henry kissinger
can you
expand on what happened with those funds
at all sure yes uh you're asking about
the the 38 thousand dollars plus the 5
000 a month that went to
uh to follow land and freedom um i'm not
sure exactly what happened to it it
wasn't a lot of money right we're
talking about tens of thousands of
dollars
and i'm sure it's not the only money
that this organization had
but these guys were not only fascist in
their ideology they were essentially
terrorists they were they were you know
youth shock troops which means they're
mostly college students high school
students and they're organizing during
the three years of the allende regime so
you have a communist
or a marxist but an elected marxist
president trying to run the country and
he's having all sorts of problems some
are financial and economic and some come
from these groups who are
you know marching in the streets but
also setting off bombs here and there
right and they're trying to prepare a
coup so they are hoping that a
pinochet-like
coup will occur and they're trying to
make it happen by sort of creating chaos
in the streets right they'll they'll
bomb an electric
uh you know power stations so as to you
know turn off the power in all of
santiago and then they'll blame it on
alien day they'll blame it on the
marxist government they do these kinds
of things so
who knows exactly where the money went
to which you know maybe it just went to
publications or radio programs that sort
of thing but maybe it did go to these
you know this real sort of
you know this subversive activity uh in
in and so that's that's pretty revealing
that our government would do that sort
of thing but you know that's that's more
or less what the cia did through lots of
people in south america they didn't do
it themselves but they gave money and
they said well you're freedom fighters
you could do whatever you want with this
money
in his life
ultimately ever have to
face
or answer for this crime
oh did finish the answer for this crime
that's a good question and it's dealt
with mostly in uh the epilogue of the
book right so the epilogue goes from
1995 when contreras and espinosa are
found guilty and they go to jail to
essentially 2018.
um
the quick answer is no pinochet never
has to answer for this crime although if
you know the story of finisher you know
that in 1998 he does have to start
answering for other crimes right he goes
to london and the spanish essentially
tried to extradite him for crimes
against spaniards and this starts this
whole process he's eventually
sent back to chile a free man but then
at this point the courts in chile have
really turned around and they're
starting you know they put him on the
docket and accuse him of all these
crimes and he dies before he's ever
right found guilty of any of them so he
pays for none of his crimes
um but it's interesting that what in the
early 1990s
while contreras is being accused of
these things and he's appearing on tv
all the time on cnn chile and so on he
starts sort of mildly accusing pinochet
of actually being the guy who gave him
the the order
right to put the hit on material he
never says it in so many words you know
chile pinochet did it but he says things
like everything i did
i did because el jefe told me to do it
everything i did as the head of dina
and so he doesn't really follow on the
logic to accuse him directly and at some
point they even have a shouting match
against this right you know pinochet is
saying no no i just gave you general
directions to
you know
deal with deal with subversives i didn't
tell you to kill anyone
and so
it's not absolutely clear from those
conversations and those shouting matches
right what contreras really meant
contreras
explanation for this particular crime
was always the same until he died he
said the cia did it
and michael townley was an agent of the
cia
right because that's a lie
that anyone in south america would
believe
right either on the left or on the right
they'll believe that the cia is able to
do these sorts of things and of course
it is able to do it and town is an
american and so it seems to make sense
right but it doesn't make sense it's not
true
um i just wanted to know
what your personal connection to the
story is and what drew you to
you know wanting to explain more from
1995 to last year
yeah
i have no deep personal connection to
the story although chile is one of the
first countries that i traveled to when
i was sort of exploring right in my
early 20s and so i spent a few months in
that country traveled from north to
south and loved it and in fact it was
during
the
the first years of you know when chilean
democracy came back so pinochet was gone
but i remember hearing about
the colony of dignity which was this
sort of concentration camp in the south
of chile that was completely private but
now we know that contreras would send
prisoners there to get tortured there's
a movie about this it came out a couple
of years ago
it's a fact several movies have come out
about this
um
so i sort of had this emotional
connection generally speaking to chile
and its people
i've had good friends come from there
and
when i started research on sort of a
next project about five years ago i was
simply interested in reagan and the
1980s in latin america and reading and i
read a pretty academic book
that was about reagan and pinochet in
fact it's called reagan and finished
it's a very good academic book
and partly it made me realize that this
story had not disappeared off the of the
ledger
by the reagan administration i thought
once they captured townley in 78 it's
essentially over but it wasn't it
remained a real bone of contention and
so intellectually i got really
interested in
why right and and how could it remain
such a bonus it's just an assassination
how could it completely change the
dynamics of these two
really close cold war allies so as to
really fracture those relations by the
end of the 1980s and so it's this it's
this assassination that is uh you know
and once you start reading about their
lives which are really kind of exposed
in this in this book you really get get
a sense of who these people are
then you really get attached to them and
you care about what happens to them and
to their families
thank you very much
thank you thank you so much alan and uh
thank you all for being here like i said
ghost of sheridan circle is on sale uh
at all of our busboys location so i
implore you to take a look at it if you
haven't already thanks again for coming
have a great night everybody thanks
again